[Music]
the apple pie is a mouth-watering treat
this pie's popularity has been centuries
in the making it dates back to the 14th
century when countries like england
denmark and sweden develop slightly
different versions all leaving fans
hungry for more
[Music]
today apple pie is mass produced to meet
demand so you can throw away your
rolling pin and let the folks at the
factory do all the work
to make the filling they empty loads of
apple slices into a huge steam heated
kettle
these apples are a firm and tart type
and have been organically grown
they add honey and apple juice and the
apple slices simmer in the liquids while
mixing blades gently blend the
ingredients
and with the slices now partially cooked
they spice up the mix with a generous
dash of cinnamon
to thicken it to a syrupy sweetness they
add tapioca flour
the blades fold the dry ingredients into
the mix as the apple slices continue to
cook
the fruit softens and releases juices
the liquids thicken to a syrupy
consistency
when the apple slices are lightly
browned this filling mix is done
these brown and syrupy slices are now
prepared and ready for the pastry shell
the shell starts with chilled premium
grade butter it's the creamiest organic
and 100 whole wheat flour is the next
ingredient in this high fiber pastry
recipe
they pour a measured amount of honey
into the pastry mix to sweeten it
they add ice cold water it's cold to
keep the butter from melting too quickly
and that means the crust will turn out
flaky
inside the pastry mixer a dough hook
blends and kneads the ingredients until
they congeal into dough the dough is
moist but not too wet and sticky
inside an apparatus called a sheeter a
mechanized roller presses the dough into
sheets
a worker drapes a sheet of dough over
groupings of four paper pie plates
which then move forward on a carousel
meanwhile overhead that syrupy apple
filling funnels into a device called a
depositor
the depositor pumps the filling into the
uncooked pie crusts
as they circle around on the loot
conveyor
this automated system fills every second
grouping of crusts right on cue
now full of sweet fruit a worker tops
them with more dough giving the pies the
upper crust
like a big revolving cookie cutter a
rolling die punch cuts the dough around
the pie plates
separating them trimming and crimping
the edges all in one action
pedestal lifts hoist the pies and a
worker transfers them to the next
conveyor
they finish one group of pies and then
start another for a continuous cycle of
pie production
[Music]
the pies now head into the baking zone
[Music]
here workers arrange the pies on baking
sheets they slice holes in the top crust
to vent steam and prevent fruit juices
from overflowing
they stack the pie laden baking sheets
on racks in a convection oven
the racks spin for a more even baking
job
they send one apple pie from each batch
to the quality assurance department
here the inspector takes in the aromas
from the freshly baked pie
she examines its form and compares it to
an existing perfect pie
slicing it confirms that the crust is
flaky
but does it have that melt-in-your-mouth
flavor there's only one way to verify
that
if the quality assurance people approve
the pie
then the whole batch moves forward
they flash freeze the pies then seal
them in cellophane
suctioning arms open cardboard
containers and a worker slides in the
pies
rollers close the pre-glued flaps
they produce more than 2100 apple pies
every hour at this factory
once the job is done there are big
decisions to be made like one scoop or
two
one slice or the whole pie
perhaps it's best just to dig in and
decide later
[Music]
you